unsere erste gesprächspartnerin ist
wieder marina weisband deutsch
ukrainerinnen in kiew geboren uns aus
münster zugeschaltet bündnisgrüne ist
sie auch noch marina sagen sie uns an
diesem auch an diesem tag zunächst wie
es ihren freunden ihrer familie in kiel
geht
ich versuche einen überblick über die
lage zu behalten im moment ist noch
verhältnismäßig ruhig sagen man hört
immer wieder schüsse explosionen aber
eher in den vorstädten im moment scheint
die lebensmittelversorgung auch noch
gesichert obwohl ich gehört habe dass in
einigen vierteln manuell wasser
ausgegeben werden muss alle machen sich
riesige sorgen um meine person und
tatsächlich sind wir heute mal
durchgegangen was passiert während einer
belagerung und wie müsste man sich
darauf einstellen in sachen persönlicher
vorräte zu hause sie haben genau das
jetzt für diese genannten städte
ausgemalt mario pohl da ist erneut der
humanitären korridor beschossen wurden
der am ende ja auch dafür sorgen soll
dass menschen natürlich die stadt
verlassen kann und man danach dann aber
in der logik dieses wladimir putin zu
flächenbombardements droht was glauben
sie wird auch nun in mario pohl weiter
geschehen
ich denke genau das also das ist ja eine
taktik die wir schon aus syrien kennen
dass man sagt die zivilisten haben jetzt
fünf stunden zeit die stadt zu verlassen
und danach gibt es per definition keine
zivilisten mehr in der stadt was
natürlich großer quatsch ist wir haben
selbst unter denen die gehen wollen
viele alte bettlägrige behinderte
menschen die einfach überhaupt nicht
gehen können und ich habe das gefühl
dass er stärker auf diese artillerie
jetzt einschwenkt weil er situationen
vermeiden möchte in denen soldaten den
bewohnerinnen der ukraine gegenüber
stehen und dieses gefühl bekommen wir
sind hier nicht als befreier wir sind
hier als invasive kraft man will uns
hier nicht und die ukraine als bruder
volk ich glaube da möchte niemand
eigentlich ging kämpfen ich wüsste nicht
wer seine leute darauf vorbereiten
sollte bei uns ist heute ernst york von
studnitz helfern stadtnetz sie waren in
einer zeit
moskau in moskau botschafter deutscher
botschafter in der wir alle hofften dass
der kalte krieg vorbei ist und sie haben
dann lange das deutsch-russische vor
umgeleitet wie enttäuscht sind sie heute
und was glauben sie wer kommt überhaupt
an wladimir putin noch heran also
komplexeres gleich aufzugreifen niemand
ich glaube putin ist in einer blase in
der er nicht mehr zugänglich ist das ist
das sehr gefährliche an der situation in
moskau heute ich sage es mal ein
bisschen mehr spitzt dass es kein
politbüro mehr gibt
zu zeiten der nachfolge stalins hat es
immer ein politbüro gegeben auch ein
zentralkomitee dass ein mann wie
kursschiff abgesetzt hat und das der
alten riege breschnjew an drop off
tschernenko ein ende bereitet hat indem
man gesagt hat 'jetzt ist aber genug
jetzt braucht man jungen mann jetzt
nehmen wir den gorbatschow
eine solche möglichkeit besteht heute in
moskau nicht denn er putin ist
alleinherrscher und die situation die
wir in der vorigen woche gesehen haben
wie er da seine seinen sicherheitsrat
zusammengerufen hat und die eigentlich
wie ein schüler oder dumme jungs da
gesessen haben und dann zum teil
abgekanzelt worden von ihm das war eine
message die nach außen geschickt wurde
ich bin hier derjenige welche der das
wort führt und ihr alle die ihr da sitzt
seit ein marionettentheater seit an
varianten theater und das ist die
gefährliche situation und das ist eine
wenn sie jetzt auf den halb den ersten
teil der frage zurückkommen bitte macht
sie das genau das macht mich nicht
bitter es hat mich einfach eine
erkenntnis gegeben die ich erst über die
jahre habe entwickeln können
ich habe putin persönlich gekannt und
habe mit ihm gespräche geführt und da
hatte ich immer das gefühl gehabt dass
ein mann der auf argumente eingeht
und ich glaube die politiker die in den
folgejahren ich bin ja 2002 oscar
fortgegangen politiker die in
folgejahren mit ihm zu tun hatten
haben auch das gefühl gehabt mit dem
kann man reden und der geht auf
argumente ein
aber das hat mehr und mehr nachgelassen
heute hört dann auch niemanden mehr und
ich meine die makro ist hingefahren
stolzes hingefahren und haben versucht
ihn davon abzubringen und hat er noch
gesagt jetzt werden die truppen
zurückgezogen auch das war eine lüge
gewesen das erinnert mich immer ein wort
von lenin der gesagt hat die lüge ist
ein legitimes mittel im kampf mit dem
klassenfeind und daran hält sich ein
mann wie putin heute
omid nouripour ist bei uns einer der
beiden vorsitzenden von bündnis90 die
grünen die außenministerin annalena
baerbock hat gesagt herr nouripour wir
werden die ukraine niemals in ihrem
schicksal überlassen was heißt das wie
weit werden die grünen gehen das kann
man so schablonenhaft nicht beantworten
wir werden von tag zu tag gucken müssen
was passiert wir sind jetzt an einem ort
an dem wir nicht sein wollten und tun
dinge die wir nicht wollten dazu gehört
zum beispiel die waffenlieferungen kann
sein dass wir auch weitere liefern
werden das werden wir jedes mal von tag
zu tag miteinander prüfen müssen und
annalena baerbock der wirklich bis zum
bitteren letzten augenblick alles dafür
getan hat damit es nicht zu diesem trick
kommt der wille hat den kreml am ende
gefehlt hat völlig recht das gehört zu
unserer verpflichtung an diesen
schwierigsten stunden den menschen in
der ukraine bei zusteht mario pohl
beispielsweise ist eine stadt die extrem
gelitten hat in den letzten jahrzehnten
und die übelste zeit hatte als die
wehrmacht den kessel gespielt hat und
die es da einfach die menschen
umgebracht hat als die deutschen ich
glaube 41 42 in mario pohl reingehen
hatte die stadt 240.000 einwohner als
sie draußen bahn hatte die stadt nur
noch 80.000 einwohner wenn das nicht
eine verpflichtung ist jetzt in diesem
augenblick genau in vergleichbaren ich
will um gottes willen nicht nachts ist
jetzt vergleich mit mit mit dem und in
die einzigartigkeit der deutschen
geschichte jetzt eben bemühen aber es
ist selbstverständlich jetzt die stunde
in der sich klärt ob wir an der auf der
richtigen seite stehen und das kann nur
auf der st der mensch der ukraine sei
ihr vorgänger robert habeck fand im mai
21 schon dass man der ukraine auch mit
waffen helfen müsse er ist dafür hart
kritisiert worden in der partei und
heute müssen sie sich von dimitri
kollege anhören dem außenminister der
ukraine das wenn deutschland diese
entscheidung waffen zu liefern früher
getroffen hätte dann hätte es diesen
krieg nicht gegeben was antworten sie
dem ukrainischen aus ich verstehe alle
gefühle in der ukraine in der dieser
stresssituation in der wirklich alles
über jemand zusammenbricht haben sie das
recht alles zu kritisieren was ihnen
einfällt ich habe allerdings ein
fragezeichen bei der frage welche waffen
in welchem umfang band verhindert hätten
dass 200.000 russische streitkräfte
mobilisiert werden wir dies geworden
sind also die balance zu halten zwischen
dialog und härte war bis zum letzten
augenblick notwendig und ab dem
augenblick an dem die russischen
streitkräfte reingegangen sind was ab
oktober absehbar war aber kein
naturgesetz war es dann klar dass jetzt
nicht mehr haltbar ist dass wir keine
waffen liefern und damit ins gesicht
nachfolge rechtskonformität auch selbst
verteidigen und wenigstens das
konzediert jetzt der grünen-vorsitzende
man hätte früher auch innerhalb der
grünen darüber nachdenken wir haben das
alle miteinander diskutiert und die
entscheidung ist so gefallen wie sie
gefallen ist
im soge auch dessen was die
vorgängerregierung gesagt hat und
gemacht hat nämlich keine legal waffen
das haben wir fortgesetzt aber wir haben
die ganze zeit seit wochen sage ich
laufe ich durch die gegend und bin damit
nicht alleine wir können nichts
ausschließen wenn der krieg wirklich
losgeht und jetzt ist er leider
ausrüstung ist und jetzt werden wir
dinge tun die wir nicht tun wollen
markus söder der csu vorsitzende und
bayerische ministerpräsident ist uns aus
münchen zugeschaltet guten abend herr
söder sie kennen bloody mir putin sie
sind eben
2020 bei einem besuch begegnet meine
erste frage wie lange haben sie daran
geglaubt dass man mit wladimir putin
ähnlich wie er von studnitz beschrieb
eigentlich ganz gut klarkommen kann
es war damals ein sehr kurzer besuch ein
gespräch in dem aber schon damals auf
viele nachfragen von mir beispielsweise
das verhalten bei der mord im tiergarten
in berlin
immer wieder ab schweifende antworten
gegeben hat also keine ernsthaften
antworten das habe ich damals schon
einen eindruck gehabt der zumindest so
war das auch die fragen nicht
eingegangen wurde ich glaube man kann
hier auch weder irgendjemand der
bundeswehr und auch sonst jemand im
westen verlangen ich glaube jeder hat
redlich sich bemüht nach normalen
internationalen gepflogenheiten mit
klaren worten mit diplomatie zu
versuchen einen weg zu finden frieden zu
erhalten wenn ein partner auf der
anderen seite der dann vom partner zu
einem letztlich auch ganz anderen
notiert wenn er das nicht will sowie der
botschafter ist gerade richtig
formuliert hat dann geht es nicht anders
das hat offenkundig eine lüge nach der
anderen gegeben und man sieht er dass
die internationale gemeinschaft sich
ganz klar dagegen wendet noch nie war
der westen so einig und ich glaube auch
dass wir in deutschland alle da seid an
zeit stehen und gemeinsam daran eine
klare position zu finden aber uns muss
klar sein jedes gespräch dass derzeit
auch wohl geführt wird bringt überhaupt
kein ergebnis null ergebnis und so
vergeht nur eine strategie hilfe für die
ukraine auf der einen seite zweitens auf
sicherung und stärkung der nato wir
haben herr söder im januar 22 januar 22
noch in der fas in der frankfurter
allgemeinen zeitung ein interview von
ihnen gelesen da sagten sie ständig neue
drohungen und immer härtere sanktionen
gegen russland das kann alleine nicht
die lösung sein und russland sei ein
schwieriger partner aber keinen feind
und auch nord stream zwei solle
betrieben werden ständig neue drohungen
immer härtere sanktionen könne allein
keine lösung sein das sind ist jetzt
anderthalb monate her
wann haben sie gedacht dass das jemand
ist mit dem man besser nicht einfach so
weiter macht
nur mit geht es da wieder
bundesregierung bis zum schluss hat die
bundeswehr oder weite teile der
bundesregierung versucht den dialog zu
suchen und ich erinnere mich dass der
bundeskanzler dass jetzt ausdrücklich
als unterstützung auch zu sehen was ich
sage ja nach moskau gereist es ebenso
wie die außenministerin und viele
gespräche geführt hat klare position was
die ukraine betrifft aber auch die
hoffnung dass es einen vernünftigen weg
geben kann und so dramatisch wie auch
ein bundeskanzler da enttäuscht wurde
bei solchen gespräch oder auch marco
beispielsweise das zeigt einfach wie auf
der anderen seite sitzt und wenn in der
internationalen politik diese art von
glaubwürdigkeit nicht mehr besteht und
wenn solche gespräche auf spitzenebene
dann quasi das gegenteil zu dem was
gesagt hat ja dann dann hat es auch
wenig sinn und deswegen ist es jetzt
weiter sinnvoll zu bemühen
verbesserungen zu erreichen es geht aber
nur indem man eben die beiden dinge noch
mal tut hilfe für die ukraine
die doppelter weise stattfindet zum
einen eben mit hilfslieferungen auch mit
den waffenlieferungen die auf den weg
gebracht und sind umgekehrt die hilfe
für menschen mit einer sehr großzügigen
und intensiven aufnahme bei uns in
deutschland in ganz europa und auf der
anderen seite schon die klare sanktionen
die auch noch weiter fortgesetzt werden
müssen auch noch verschärft und für die
ende der reden und die stärkung der nato
das ist glaube ich auch nochmal ganz
wichtig um zu zeigen dass die nato einig
und geschlossen ist und dass der etwaige
übergriffe oder oder drogen wie sie auch
ausgesprochen werden eine klare grenze
bekommen wir genau an diesem punkt der
zu weil nämlich claus kleber bei uns ist
geschätzter wurde radtour des heute
journals das hat ja viele viele jahre
gemacht und die welt weiß dass er einer
der besten usa kenner ist mehrere
dokumentationen darüber gemacht hat und
wie kein zweiter sich auch mit der nato
auskennt claus kleber wer da alles zu
diesem bloody mir putin gereist ist ist
schon genannt und gesagt was glauben sie
worauf wartet ihr wirklich latina putin
also die beste hoffnung ist dass er für
eine nach einer gelegenheit sucht in aus
dieser falle in der sich selber rein
manövriert hat wieder rauszukommen oft
heißt das im diplomaten talk der
offensichtlich auch englisch dominiert
ist also die ideale rampe runter la vida
von der rampe irgendwie wieder
runterkommen in einer situation die er
wahrscheinlich auch nicht so erwartet
hat wie sie sich jetzt entwickelt hat
und ich muss sagen wenn ich jetzt höre
wie sich die wir alle überlegen ob
dieses viele reden mit russland usw ob
das überhaupt noch sinn hatte
natürlich hatte es damals ich glaube
dass
die nato sich selber und der westen sich
selber nicht zugetraut hätte damals im
januar lange her
was er jetzt zustande gebracht hat
nämlich eine wirklich einheitliche
haltung da sind da die macher dieser
haltung sind selber überrascht wie gut
das klappt und das liegt daran dass so
lange haben die norddeutschen haben wir
alles für die spd die regierung und die
opposition dazu über die regierung da
sind viele sachen zusammengekommen putin
hat sich verschätzt in der
leistungsfähigkeit seiner eigenen armee
in diesem konkreten fall er hat völlig
unterschätzt den widerstand der ukraine
er hat die persönlichkeit von zielinski
wie viele im westen auch falsch
eingeschätzt und ich glaube das ist ganz
ganz wichtig war dass sie zellen ski
jetzt nicht wie janukowitsch damals
abgehauen ist in der nacht sondern die
entscheidende zeit geblieben ist und
dieses angebot der amerikaner wir holen
dich raus spektakulär abgelehnt hat er
gesagt hat ich brauche keine
fahrgelegenheit ich brauch lassen
das hat dem westen die
48 72 stunden gegeben in denen der sich
zusammengefunden hat wenn das nicht so
gewesen wäre wäre die verteidigung der
ukraine schon am nächsten tag ein lost
calls eine aussichtslose mission gewesen
und hinter einer aussichtslosen mission
hätte sich nie der westen so versammelt
wie er sich jetzt versammelt hat es ist
schon eine komische geschichte dass ein
komiker mit seiner persönlichen
art mit diesen portalen bekenntnis zur
unabhängigen ukraine auf diese weise
innerhalb von minuten wird geschichte
gemacht hat jetzt ist das ergebnisoffen
und stellt riesenprobleme wenn das nicht
gewesen wäre wäre die ukraine jetzt
schon überrollt und wir hätten mit einer
ganz anderen situation zu und es hat
diesen krieg gebraucht um uns alle so
zusammen zu führen und diese besondere
situation gebraucht um uns zu einem auch
die europäer und die nato zu einem und
dafür zu sorgen dass wir nun sogar
darüber nachdenken
wie wir die ukraine auch militärisch
unterstützen können und sind in der
nächsten sorgen eskalation ja aber es
ist ja schon insofern ein luxusproblem
weil eine eine untergegangene ukraine
ein triumph von putin ein ungefährdeter
fast triumph von putin in der ukraine
die geschichte europas in eine andere
richtung gelenkt hätte als jetzt möglich
erscheint das wird nicht leicht
auch das wird große opfer kosten wird
viel kopfzerbrechen machen weil ja alles
besser als wir aber es ist besser als
das scheitern der europäischen ordnung
die bestanden hat man kann sagen vom
neunter november 89
bis zum vergangenen mittwoch deshalb ist
es richtig zu sagen dass die ukraine
gerade für uns diesen fight auch fährt
deshalb ist es notwendig auch zu sehen
dass sie gerade ihre demokratie
verteidigen und damit im systemischen
wettbewerb unsere demokratie und unsere
freiheit mit verteidigen es ist einfach
nicht zu verkennen dass wir an der seite
ihrer stehen müssen weil das unser feind
ist weil das unser aller kampf ist um
unsere lebensweise auch zu verteidigen
gegen rohre und robuste gewalt dennoch
ist es nicht zurückkommen wollte ich
gerade sagen und sie sind mir nicht böse
wenn ich die marina weisband zunächst
noch mal zu uns bitte um nach russland
zu schauen und nach moskau zu schauen
und in die vielen städte zu gucken
marina in denen heute demonstriert wurde
insgesamt 60 städte
4400 menschen sind sofort verhaftet
worden ihnen droht 15 jahre haft nach
diesen neuen kriegsrecht dass putin
verhängt hat navalny sagt aus dem
gefängnis die menschen mögen
protestierenden wie ernst zu nehmen ist
diese opposition in russland und
überschätzen wie wir sie hier in europa
indes ob das sehr dass es sehr sehr
schwierig zu beantworten erstens wenn
wir eine sache gelernt haben dann man
darf niemals die
wirkung von menschen und die wirkung
einer idee unterschätzen aber das geht
in zwei richtungen einerseits sind diese
oppositionellen die da stehen auf den
straßen helden sie sind helden weil sie
tatsächlich fast schon todesmutig
agieren weil sie wissen dass ihnen
gefängnis droht weil sie wissen dass
nicht nur ihnen sondern ihren familien
für kastanien drohen putin drehte er im
moment die schraube in
schwindelerregender geschwindigkeit
zurück zum stalinismus ich weiß dass er
eigentlich die ideologie des des
touristischen russischen imperiums
verfolgt aber in den repressionen nach
innen kennen wir das eigentlich aus dem
aus dem mitte des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts
also dieser menschen sind helden sie
sie sind im moment sehr schwer zu
organisieren weil alle starken stimmen
der zivilgesellschaft wie zb in der wahl
wurden eingesperrt oder eben getötet und
das ist sehr zielgerichtet passiert in
den letzten jahren eben damit jetzt
diese
demonstrationen kein kipp punkt
erreichen das sind meistens die
mittelschichten ist meistens die
jüngeren leute meistens in den städten
um sie ist es am tragischen weil das
sind die die verstehen was vor sich geht
das sind die die verstehen dass es
falsch ist und das sind die die trotzdem
bestraft werden sowohl von ihrem eigenen
staat als auch von unseren sind er darf
aber nicht aus dem blick verlieren daher
mit ihn auch unterstützt wird von einem
sehr großen teil seiner bevölkerung der
acht jahre lang das gehirn gewaschen
wurde der acht jahre lang trainer innen
entmenschlicht geworden der bei der
faschistische feind präsentiert wurde
der dekadente und schwule westen und der
dieser gedanke ist dass der russe etwas
besonderes sein und über den westen
haben sei immer und immer wieder vor
augen geführt wurde und ich glaube auch
das dürfen wir nicht unterschiedlich wir
können und wollen an der stelle herrn
von studnitz unbedingt fragen sie haben
aus protest in der letzten woche einen
freundschaftsorden zurückgegeben diesen
orten haben sie 2011 bekommen von
medwedew glaube ich gab es schon
irgendeine reaktion des botschafters und
was wissen sie glauben sie könnte man
hoffen auf die menschen die in diesem
apparat von putin arbeiten wir haben
gerade über die opposition auf moskaus
straßen gesprochen gibt es auch in
diesem apparat vielleicht noch menschen
die vernünftig sind oder haben sie das
mit was schwierig vorhersagen schon aus
nein das würde ich nicht ausschließen
nur die situation so wie ich sie
einschätze in moskau heute in putins
moskau ist so dass die leute die
widerstand leisten würden angst haben
und die werden sich nicht dekorieren
die werden nicht aus der deckung kommen
und zeigen dass die gegner von putin
sinnvoll wären sofort die presse- und so
die repression droht deshalb wird und
deshalb glaube ich auch wie kleber es
eben angedeutet hat ob es eine
möglichkeit gibt dass putin sozusagen
von der rampe runter kommen das sehe ich
nicht der judo kämpfer mit seinem
schwarzen gürtel ja der kämpft so lange
wie er kämpfen kann der wird nicht
aufhören und daran sehe ich die große
gefahr dass das der krieg in der ukraine
wird irgendwann zu ende gehen ich
fürchte mit einer mehr oder weniger
totalen vernichtung des landes aber das
wird kein sieg für putin werden denn was
will er mit einem zerstörten land was er
erreicht haben wird ist eine endlich
geschlossene ukraine die nie wieder zu
russland gehören will und das wollte ja
der putin gerade verhindern er wollte
die frau was man tut es eben gesagt er
hatte diesen imperialen traum des
ehemaliges sowjetreich so weiter ist
wieder zusammen sammeln könnte und klein
russland wieder zurückzuholen
zurückzuholen und das wird ihm nicht
gelingen
er hat schon vorher und der putin ist
eigentlich getrieben von angst er hat
schon vorher angst gehabt dass in der
ukraine ein demokratisches modell
gelingen könnte die ukraine wir haben
sie sehr kritisiert mit vielen
korruption und so weiter und so fort um
mit pedro schenken wollen wir keineswegs
einverstanden
und wir haben auch schon gesagt wurde
poroschenko und wie es eben auch schon
gesagt worden hat eigentlich dem dem
jetzige präsident nicht wirklich
zugetraut dass er das leisten könnte
aber dass dort der weg zur demokratie
schon soweit begangen worden ist das ist
für putin eine wirkliche gefahr die
gefahr der farben revolution deshalb
gegen georgien vorgegangen ist weshalb
gegen die
entmachtung von janukowitsch schon so
heftig reagiert hat die gefahr besteht
für ihn dass das in moskau auch
passieren könnte und deshalb wehrt er
sich und genau das ist die gefahr und
mit diesem denken markus söder sind wir
auch bei dem was er uns immer wieder in
erinnerung rufen will nämlich dass er
atomwaffen hat er hat nicht zum ersten
mal darauf aufmerksam gemacht und damit
gedroht
tschernobyl ist zunächst besetzt wurden
von russischen truppen jetzt in der
letzten woche auch ein weiteres
ukrainisches
atomkraftwerk nun hat sich der cdu
vorsitzender friedrich merz dazu
geäußert und hat gesagt es ist einen
punkt geben kann an dem die nato putin
vielleicht stoppen
schließen sie sich seine gedanken daran
oder sagen sie das ist brandgefährlich
ich glaube er hat es auch gestern noch
mal anders formuliert also zunächst mal
ist eines ganz klar es ist kein nato
fall weil die ukraine nicht in der nato
ist trotzdem helfen wir weil es nämlich
eine frage der freiheit ist der
menschenrechte und indirekt natürlich
auch der sicherheit von ganz europa der
zweite teil ist diese drohungen mit
insbesondere nuklearwaffen kammer
zweigeteilt sind zum einen ist natürlich
schon ein ungeheuerliches dass man in
diesen tagen mit in diesen zeiten mit
nuklearwaffen droht umgekehrt aber ist
das auch kein zeichen von stärke wenn
ich an den botschafter anschließend ein
zeichen von schwäche natürlich denn in
der tat läuft der krieg nicht so wie
sich putin das vorgestellt hat er muss
ja mit unglaublichen mühen und
aufwendiger argumentation zu hause jetzt
auch mit einem gesetz das quasi jede
andere meinung unterdrücken soll auch
verhindern dass er in russland die
nachrichten einziger über die
schwierigkeit des krieges es bleibt ja
auch nicht verborgen wenn russische
soldaten fallen es bleibt ja auch nicht
vertragen wenn junge soldaten gar nicht
wissen dass sie den krieg ziehen und
auch ganz überrascht sind dass sie nicht
mit freudentaumel und und und blumen
begrüßt werden sondern mit heftiger
gegenwehr rechnen müssen all das ganze
ist in der tat zeichen von schwächen
genau diese unsicherheit kommt deswegen
ist ja auch die unterstützung für
belarus für lukaschenko so groß gewesen
das ist ja auch so eine panikattacke
gewesen und dort zu sehen was könnte
dort auch drohnen was vielleicht auch
bei mir passiert das heißt also
umgekehrt wir müssen uns zunächst mal
auch in zwei bereichen nochmals stärken
die nato selbst stark zu machen also ich
finde es schon jetzt ein wichtiges
zeichen dass jetzt in den letzten wochen
gelungen ist der kleber hat völlig recht
inso kürzester zeit so eine einigkeit in
der nato war selten man hat das bei der
münchner sicherheitskonferenz erlebt ich
kann mich noch in ein letztes und
vorletztes jahr war das alles wesentlich
differenzierter schwieriger jetzt ganz
klar ich selbst hab neue soldaten aus
den usa empfangen die bei uns waren das
war ich sage es aber mal wieder ein
gutes gefühl der gemeinsamkeit trotz
dieser schweren zeit und deswegen müssen
wir jetzt auch alles tun unsere
bundeswehr so stark zu machen damit sie
nicht nur dauerhaft sondern auch jetzt
den einsatz leisten kann der aus dem
simulator aus flanke zu schützen also
die nicht alle zusammen je stärker wir
die nato machen desto klarer zeigen mir
halt stopp schild für putin und noch
einmal friedrich merz hat nicht gemeint
so habe ich ihn auch verstanden dass wir
sozusagen eine nato fall auslösen müssen
sondern was es geht ist die frage und
wie waren weitere sanktionen machen kann
dass das eine die auch darauf wirken
verschärfen und umgekehrt noch weitere
hilfslieferungen möglicherweise auch
waffen an die ukraine liefert und also
nicht darüber nachdenkt wie man tut ihn
vielleicht auch stoppen muss wir sind
herr nouripour bei der frage wie groß
ist ihre angst dass das eskalieren kann
dass jemand der sich in die ecke
gedrängt fühlt und nun einer so massiven
und überraschenden gegenwert der welt
gegenüber steht genau das gegenteil von
dem was man sich wünschen würde nämlich
die waffen zu strecken und zu sagen ich
lasse ab von meinem plan also es gibt
den schlauen adams wirtschaftshistoriker
der im spiegel sagt wir hatten ja auch
gedacht dass unsere sanktionen quasi
später kommen also nach einer in einem
fall der ukraine als eine bestrafung für
diesen waffengang von putin jetzt
passieren sie parallel und er kann sie
als kriegshandlung interpretiert wie
groß ist ihre sorge dass das eskaliert
ich sage ja schon gesagt hat er das sagt
die wirtschaftsredaktion sein so etwas
wie eine kriegserklärung glaube das ist
das zitat man muss einfach sich immer
wieder vergegenwärtigen dass das gesamte
system sowohl in russland als auch in
dem was er als einflusssphäre versteht
darauf basiert dass die menschen angst
haben und diese angst können wir uns
nicht leisten natürlich ist das
besorgniserregend wenn ein land mit so
vielen atomsprengköpfen dann dann
anfängt darüber zu räsonieren dass man
ja auch nukleare herzschläge tatsächlich
verüben kann und ja wir werden alles
dafür tun müssen damit das nicht
passiert und ja die gesprächskanäle
müssen offen bleiben und ja wenn er
reden will dann muss gibt es die
einhellige bereitschaft aller staaten
der europäischen union und der nato mit
ihm zu sprechen auch der ukraine aber
der kreml ist nicht ans telefon gegangen
als als lenski angerufen hat und deshalb
kann ich nur appellieren dass wir eine
sehr genau hingucken
versuchen auch alles dafür zu tun damit
wir dem gewappnet sind und da gibt es
sehr viel was wir werden tun müssen aber
angst hilft nicht angst hilft nur die
sind claus kleber stern habe ich schon
gesagt am freitag diese diese zweite
ukrainische atomkraftwerk das größte
dass es in europa gibt auf der anderen
seite sagt sie herr lavrov der
außenminister dass der dritte weltkrieg
ein atomarer weltkrieg ist warum teilt
der uns diese selbstverständlichkeit mit
was möchte er der welt sagen außer uns
in angst und schrecken zu versetzen das
würde ja schon reichen also angst wie
herr nouripour sagte ist ja auch ein
lärm faktor
angst will ich nicht sagen befürchtungen
muss man haben im moment ist für den
verlauf der ereignisse in der ukraine
mit entscheidend die versorgung mit
relativ kleinen aber sehr wirksame
waffen der ukrainischen streitkräfte mit
panzerbrechenden waffen zum beispiel die
über polen eingeführt werden es ist eine
militärische selbstverständlichkeit zu
versuchen diesen nachschub irgendwie zu
stoppen was wenn jetzt irgendeine
russische einheit die ja ohnehin im
grenzgebiet schon unterwegs ist
beschließt jetzt nicht mehr genau auf
zehn kilometer zu achten und den
nachschubweg
zu bombardieren in polen
wird dann die nato sofort bei der ersten
explosion einer bombe auf polnischem
territorium der nato verteidigungsfall
mit allen eskalation möglichkeiten aus
rufen hört man kann nur hoffen sagt ja
aber man kann nur hoffen dass es dazu
nicht kommt denn dann geraten die dinge
außer rand und band
deswegen wie das zeigt einem wie wie eng
das plötzlich geworden ist das
gefährlich werden heute noch durch
deutschland wir fahren in berlin durch
die stadt
einem absoluten gefühl von sicherheit um
zur maybrit illner zu gehen diese
selbstverständlichkeiten das haben wir
jetzt in den letzten zehn tagen gesehen
sind keine selbstverständlichkeit mehr
und die lage ist extrem heikel
unerfreulicher weise egal ob putin die
oberhand gewinnt oder in die ecke
getrieben ist beides ist gleichermaßen
gefällt es gibt diese sogenannten
taktischen atomwaffen danach wollte ich
noch mal fragen das sind kleinere
regional begrenzt wirkende so furchtbar
sich das anhört die er eben in einzelnen
städten der ukraine einsetzen könnte
wenigstens gibt es diese angst dort ja
was wird und winken sehen lassen welchen
sinn hätte das
was in der debatte über atomwaffen immer
auch in deutschland vergessen worden ist
es wie grauenhaft wirkungsvoll
massenhaft wirkungsvoll konventionelle
waffen geworden sind die thermo waren
waffen wo jetzt schon immer mal wieder
gesagt wurde die seien eingesetzt worden
ich glaube es nicht ganz
sie können mit konventionellen waffen
unbeschreibliche verwüstungen anrichten
und je weniger beschädigen auch das und
das territorium dass sie ja beherrschen
wollen
schonen quasi
was so würde es ihm dringend jetzt
sozusagen mutwillig wenn dasselbe
auch miteinander war für erreicht werden
könnte jetzt ausgerechnet eine taktische
atomwaffen zu sich mir hat noch keiner
erklären können welchen vorteil dass für
putin hätte diese schwelle zu übertreten
eine aber damit zu spielen mit diesem
gedanken dass immer wieder zu sagen weil
er genau weiß die amerikaner werden mit
sicherheit nicht als erster eine
atomwaffe einsetzen drum kann er relativ
gefahrlos mit dieser idee spielen
wiederum um angst zu verbreiten wieweit
marina weiß man glauben sie kann der
westen da gehen und wie weit denken sie
wann wird sich putin in die ecke
gedrängt fühlen und es könnte eben zu
einer weiteren eskalation führen das ist
so eine wahnsinnig schwere gratwanderung
die man auch nicht gut beschreiben kann
helfen sie uns
ach so ich
mit ihm fühlt sich schon in die ecke
gedrängt
analysten im russischen bereich im
russischen radio solange es echo moskau
noch gab gaben russland jetzt mit den
sanktionen eine lebenszeit von ein paar
monaten bevor die ganze ökonomie flöten
geht solange die zentralbankreserven
nicht wieder freigegeben werden und das
bedeutet er ist im prinzip schon in die
ecke gedrängt und es gibt die theorie
dass er sich im moment wie ein
spielsüchtiger benimmt das heißt er hat
schon bestimmte kosten versenkt und
jetzt erhielt er einfach nur noch die
einsätze und erhöht und erhöht und
erhöhte in einer gewissen verblendung
und soweit ich verstehe steht dahinter
auch diese relativ mächtige ideologische
ja sekte fast schon der eurasia um einen
bogen
der seit den späten 90ern eigentlich
dieses große russische imperium
propagiert und irgendwann ist diese
sekte mit putins petersburger klüngel so
verschmolzen und die frage ist jetzt
eigentlich wie sehr ist dieser
petersburger klüngel also die macht
menschen um putin herum wie sehr sind
die ebenfalls indoktriniert von dieser
idee und wie sehr sind sie noch
realpolitiker die auch ihrem urlaub im
westen schätzen und die wollen dass ihre
kinder im ausland studieren das ist
glaube ich die zentrale frage auf die es
gerade ankommt denn das ist die frage ob
putin im amt bleibt oder nicht und zur
ukraine die habe ich übrigens er braucht
gar keine atombomben dort einsetzen er
hat atomkraftwerkes reicht völlig wenn
du den unfall passiert das ist nun auch
schon geschehen zum glück war dass ein
brand in einem aufenthalt gebäude wenn
ich das richtig gelesen habe und ihre
sorge die sorge ihre freunde davor ist
wie gross marina weisband
sehr groß sehr groß weil die west
ukraine braucht putin nicht er kann da
gut ein exempel statuieren damit die ost
ukraine zu ihnen kommt es gibt die
theorie dass sie die ukraine plant in
drei teile zu teilen dass er die west
ukraine laufen lässt dass viele in der
mitte einer marionettenregierung
einsetzt und den osten zu sich holt er
ist einfach ein moment für alle
unberechenbar von murat auf dem
chefredakteur der nowaja gaseta von ihm
lasen wir das gerade kürzlich
und das hört sich alles nicht gut an es
gibt hier von studnitz die überlegung
schweden und norwegen in die nato zu
finden und vielleicht entschuldigungen
himmel schwebt und finnland in die nato
zu holen eben auch um das baltikum
besser zu schützen um diese situation
jetzt auszunutzen seitens der nato
würden sie sagen das wäre auch so eine
rote linie die
man auf gar keinen fall überschreiten
sollte oder dächten sie das wäre ein
guter schachzug die finnen denken über
die frage des anschlusses an die nato
seit jahrzehnten nach richtig und haben
das immer sehr sehr vorsichtig gespielt
bis zum heutigen tage und wissen ganz
genau dass ein beitritt finnlands der
den beitritt schwedens und mit nach sich
zöge eine deutliche herausforderung
russlands wäre und dass das der putin
wahrscheinlich diesen dieses weitere
heranrücken der nato an seine grenzen
und das sind 1300 kilometer gemeinsame
grenze die finnland mit dem nördlichen
russland hat das dass der putin
vermutlich nicht ohne
gegenreaktion auf sich nehmen wird und
deshalb sind die finden so sehr sehr
zurückhaltend und vorsichtig in der
entscheidung ob sie da eintreten wollen
oder nicht
andererseits brauchen sie es auch im
gegenwärtigen augenblick nicht wirklich
weil die finden wie auch die schweden
eigentlich sehr eng mit der nato auch
ohne mitgliedschaft kooperieren nur die
nach hinzu kommt noch eine
finnland hat zwar nur eine kleine armee
von ungefähr 35.000 und 40.000 mann aber
hat einer ausgebildeten bestand von
reservisten von mehr als 500.000 das ist
also eine wirkliche militärische potenz
die da steht
und was die finnen bedeuten für russland
das wissen die russen seitdem
winterkrieg 1939 40 da haben sie sich
schon einmal die zähne ausgebissen und
mit den finnen ist nicht gut kirschen
essen und wir sind mit dieser frage
trotzdem noch mal dabei claus kleber
ganz kurz bevor wir nach deutschland
kommen zu einzuschätzen was die nato
jetzt eigentlich noch tun kann sie muss
er aufpassen es drohen viele viele
gefahren und es sind wahnsinnig heiße
eisen die dazu bewegen sind aber über
welche strategischen über welche
taktischen dinge kann die nato jetzt
noch nachdenken die helfen könnten putin
das gefühl zu geben dass er gut
beobachtet wird sagen dass also die die
größte herausforderung für die nato im
moment ist die schutzgarantie des
artikel 5 nato vertrag einer für alle
alle für einen
absolut scharif abzugrenzen und
einzuhalten weil es 1 1
auch mit hilfe der versuch mit diesen
atomen begriffen zu spielen und so
weiter und vielleicht kleinen
grenzübertritten
wird damit rechne ich fest putin
versuchen diese dieses feste bündnis so
ein bisschen an zulagen
und immer wieder die frage zu stellen
lohnt sich sie es wegen dieser
kleinigkeit den artikel 5 auszurufen und
da rechtzeitig rote linien zu ziehen die
dann leider auch eingehalten werden
müssen das wäre jetzt ganz wichtig in
dieser in dieser schwierigen situation
im moment um klar zu machen ist
ukraine ist nicht mitglied der nato nur
deswegen konnte es so weit kommen polen
und die baltischen staaten sind ist ohne
jeden zweifel
ziehen und sich nicht nur t home und
dann schauen sie nur die situation weil
da wie in transnistrien an es gibt so
viele ungeklärte fragen und im baltikum
wo sie in lettland eine russische
bevölkerung 5 40 prozent haben die auch
noch starke verbindung tatsächlich nach
russland haben es gibt da viele
möglichkeiten zu zündeln und das ist
glaube ich das hauptproblem der nato im
moment dass die zulieferung von waffen
und so weiter das hat sich jetzt schon
eingespielt da haben sich auch grenzen
eingezogen und mehr wird das nicht
möglich sein aber dann der nato vertrag
muss jetzt halten sonst wäre der krieg
putins gegen die ukraine würde mit einer
niederlage der nato enden wenn sie ihre
bündnis versprechen nicht mehr
aufrechterhalten kann und das wäre der
optimale ausgang für putin und die
katastrophe für den westen der arbeit
nicht sein wird
eine katastrophe für die welt natürlich
wir sind markus söder bei der frage der
deutschen hilfe die deutschen in dieser
situation
sind seit dem sonntag und einer rede des
bundeskanzlers olaf scholz entschieden
der ukraine nicht nur zu helfen sondern
die bundeswehr mit 100 milliarden in
einen wesentlich besseren zustand zu
versetzen das ist jetzt ein harter
schnitt und wir helfen konkret mit
helmen und
verrosteten raketen aus nva besteht wie
erklären sie sich dass und hat es auch
etwas damit zu tun dass
sie 16 jahre lang verteidigungsminister
der cdu/csu am start waren
also zum einbau ist das eine gute
entscheidung des bundeskanzlers gewesen
die größte investition in die bundeswehr
seit ihrer gründung zu machen und auch
klar zu machen dass die 100 milliarden
nur für die bundeswehr sind und auch das
2 prozent ziel parallel erfüllt werden
muss und dazu gehört tatsächlich den
auftrag der bundeswehr neu zu
reformieren mit mir so ein
landesverteidigung und im mittelpunkt zu
rücken nicht nur die einsatzarmee zum
zweiten auch munition bestände nachschub
zu organisieren und auch neue luft
systeme und neue auch waffen auf den weg
zu bringen so dass erst das zweite ist
es die letzten zehn zwölf jahre lange
diskutierte bundeswehr es gab immer
wieder vorschläge des zu stärken mehr
geld zu investieren
das ist in der großen koalition
gescheitert es lag glaube ich nicht an
den verteidigungsministern sondern das
war in der koalition nicht möglich sie
haben ja auch gemerkt hat im einen
anderen aus den parteien der ampel also
auch bei der spd gibt es diskussionen
bringen tut uns das heute alles glaube
ich aber nichts also weder die
schuldzuweisung noch da sondern ich
finde jetzt gut dass jetzt endlich
investiert wird und dass mehr gemacht
wird allerdings hängt bei der bundeswehr
nicht alles am geld sondern auch an der
struktur die art und weise der
beschaffungen ist schon wirklich
unterirdisch anders kann das gar nicht
sagt extrem kompliziert und es gibt
quasi nur indem man die bundeswehr neu
aufstellt auch bei der frage der
gesamten beschaffung der ganzen neuen
systeme schneller effektiver macht und
in dem man endlich auch dinge wie
bewaffnete drohnen beispielsweise auf
den weg die nukleare teilhabe sicher
dass jetzt ganz entscheidend für die
sicherheit der nato und insofern werden
wir auch als union alles dafür tun dass
dieser ansatz erfolgreich umgesetzt
werden muss werde bedarf nicht zerredet
und verwässert wird genau und nur noch
mal eine nachfrage zu ebendieser
beschaffung weil darum geht es ja es ist
nicht wenig geld ausgegeben worden also
da es waren ja auch im letzten jahr 65
milliarden wenn ich richtig im kopf habe
unter vor 60 milliarden und immer und
immer wieder ist das alles in einem
irrsinnigen wasserkopf und in elend
langen bestellvorgängen verflossen wo
die fdp jetzt dann auch sagte da haben
wir irgendwie eigene waffen erfunden und
haben uns nicht an märkten bedient und
keine ordentliche ausstattung für die
soldaten organisiert ziehen sie der cdu
csu der jacke an oder sagen sie wir
haben alles getan was wir konnten und
die spd es ja
ja das wäre beides wäre zu einfach es
wird beides so einfach zu sagen da ist
jetzt ein verteidigungsminister oder
verteidigungsministerin schuld gewesen
ich war in der große einschnitt bei der
bundeswehr kam zum einen mit der
abschaffung der wehrpflicht und der
damals verbunden extremen aus meiner
sicht kaum gerecht fertigen einsparungen
die man damals gemacht hat seit der zeit
im grunde genommen hängt die bundeswehr
da an der stelle hinterher das ist schon
durch und so was eine das zweite ist es
dann im nachgang aber immer wieder bei
entscheidenden neuen waffensystemen oder
auch bei der verbesserten ausstattung
nicht die entsprechenden mehrheiten
gegeben und ist dritter das stimmt es
ist nahezu jeder und es wird auch vor
lamprecht zu gehen es wird nahezu jeder
verteidigungsminister an dieser inneren
struktur dieses beschaffungswesens
erscheinen sind zwar unzählige berater
eingesetzt worden um es zu verbessern
ich bin ja dann unmittelbar beteiligt
kann es nur von aussagen als auch im
ministerpräsident in verbindung mit
vielen unternehmen die daran beteiligt
sind aber auch vielen soldaten die ja
bei uns stationiert sind das geht nur so
in dem man dieses system komplett neu
startet um anders angeht sonst wird's
nicht funktioniert wir haben jetzt
wenigstens ein vertreter dieser ampel
und ein spitzenvertreter dieser neuen
regierung an diesem tisch zu sitzen
hervor und sie müssen das jetzt alles
neu machen ausgerechnet die grünen
müssen jetzt das
verteidigungsministerium aber mal
ehrlich aufräumen unter sachen in die
regale stellen mit denen die soldaten im
bilde wirklich etwas anfangen können
wird ihnen das gelingen und wie sehr
weit er hat es dabei wir müssen sich
mein herr söder sagt er war nicht
beteiligt ich habe selbst selbst jahre
gefühlte jahre meines lebens in
untersuchungsausschüssen gesessen in
denen wir über verbrannte steuermittel
gesprochen haben die nicht dazu geführt
haben dass es mehr sicherheit gibt und
dass die bundeswehr besser funktioniert
sondern einfach irgendwie verbrannt
worden sind weil das beschaffungswesen
so ist wie es gerade ja völlig zurecht
beschrieben hat und diese aufstellung
ist selbstverständlich aufgabe gewesen
der verteidigungsminister der
vergangenheit und er habe es nicht
gemacht und die farben haben sie gerade
beschrieben jetzt erwarten wir natürlich
und helfen wo wir können der
verteidigungsministerin damit sie all
das was in den letzten jahren nicht
passiert ist mit großer großer
geschwindigkeit nach holt damit wir wenn
wir jetzt deutlich mehr geld in die hand
nehmen wir ihn zwei jahre nicht wieder
in untersuchungsausschüssen sitzen wo
die frage kommt wie habt ihr das denn
eigentlich ausgegeben das hat mir
überhaupt nicht zu mehr sicherheit
geführt jetzt wieder hubschrauber die
nicht fliegen und so weiter und so
weiter wir haben jetzt eine zäsur die
die jetzige bundesregierung in die lage
versetzt all diese liegen gebliebenen
hausaufgaben in einer unglaublichen
geschwindigkeit erfüllen zu müssen das
ist bei der energiefrage genau dasselbe
so kommen wir ja gleich wahrscheinlich
und dementsprechend wird es auch bei der
bundeswehr sein
der letzte träger
fantastilliarden ins militär investiert
hat weil er sagte wenn wir hunderte
milliarden reinstecken müssen die russen
aufgeben und deswegen hat er das gemacht
da wird dazu führte dass das die armee
wirklich stückpreis 150 dollar das war
damals noch mehr geld als heute sich
hemmer gekauft hat bloß um die mittel
abfließen zu lassen die sie nicht mehr
verkaufen konnten genau das hat die zahl
von 100 milliarden gehört habe sich um
gottes willen wie wollen die ja sehr
sinnvoll also nur zwei sätze dazu
erstens deshalb braucht es jetzt eine
valide projektliste damit man weiß wofür
es ausgegeben werden soll jenseits einer
beschaffung eines beschaffungswesens was
endlich sinn macht und zweitens ist es
natürlich zu gucken in welchem
zeitrahmen das geld ausgegeben wird wir
uns in den nächsten vier fünf sechs
jahren ausgeben dann werden wir wie der
in untersuchungsausschüssen sitzen das
ist mir lieber herr nouripour dieses
zwei prozent ziel der nato in den
koalitionsverhandlungen immer abgelehnt
die grünen waren dagegen die fdp macht
darauf aufmerksam dass sie seit 2014
immer für das zwei prozent ziel war eine
ganz wichtige frage ist glauben sie dass
olaf scholz dass der bundeskanzler eine
eigene mehrheit zusammen bekommt wenn
sie sich die traurigen gesichter mancher
ihrer abgeordneten und abgeordneten
anschauen der bundeskanzler kann die
reden halten der marke ist dazu frei
aber am ende des tages braucht auch
mehrheiten das ist der sinn einer
koalition ist überhaupt kein problem und
darüber reden wir mit mehrheit die 2
prozent
klar ampel mehrheiten sind der braucht
natürlich eine ampel mehrheit sonst
kommt herr söder und sagte er da ist ja
überhaupt nicht handlungsfähig und
dementsprechend noch mal zu den zwei
prozent die zwei prozent waren und
bleiben falsch sind aber eine
eingegangene internationale
verpflichtung deutschland und wir haben
deshalb im koalitionsvertrag
reingeschrieben wir wollen drei prozent
ausgeben für die
verteidigung aber auch für
entwicklungszusammenarbeit und für
diplomatie weil auch dort einfach zu
wenig geld ausgegeben wird und daran
setzen wir jetzt und werden jetzt
genauer arbeiten damit wir das geld
sinnvoll ausgeben damit es wirklich mehr
sicherheit gibt und nicht mehr
verbranntes geld sie sind schon x-fach
danach gefragt worden wann sie
eigentlich informiert wurden über die
höhe dieser unterstützung oder diese
sondervermögens wie es jetzt heißen soll
verraten sie es am sonntagabend oder ist
es auch ungünstiger zeitpunkt haben sie
es vor frau baerbock und herrn beck
erfahren oder auch dann erst am sonntag
ich hab das sicher nicht vor den beiden
hervor hand über das ist
selbstverständlich dass die
kabinettsmitglieder zuerst informiert
werden vom bundeskanzler wenn das nur
wiederholen der bundeskanzler hält die
reden der für notwendig erachtet und
dann setzen wir zusammen überlegen wie
es in der koalition umgesetzt wird damit
alle mittragen und das heißt sie
antworten nicht auf die frage wann sie
informiert wurden von olaf scholz
christian lindner ist ist offensichtlich
die spitze der fdp offensichtlich auch
wann die grünen spitze es habe auch cdu
wollte gesehen die am nächsten tag
gesagt haben wir haben immer alles
gewusst dass das glaube ich jetzt eine
in einer ware in der polizei in berlin
aber die realität ist am ende das was
wir im paket reinstecken und dass wir zu
mehr sicherheit kommen in einer extrem
schwierigen situation
wir sind bei der frage markus söder wie
wir auch ein energieproblem in diesem
land
da gab es am heutigen abend eine menge
interessante nachrichten in bezug auf
nord trieben 1 es gibt also noch eine
energie leitung mit russlands die
funktioniert und die den westen weiter
mit gas versorgt wenn wir das richtig
verstehen überlegt sowohl die eu als
auch der amerikanische außenminister
auch da ein embargo zu verhängen also
diese letzte möglichkeit
der energie zulieferung zu stoppen und
zu beenden norbert röttgen fordert dass
auch das nicht mehr 200 millionen pro
tag aus deutschland in das russische
system marschieren was sagt der
bayerische ministerpräsident
so emotional spricht vieles dafür alles
zu kaufen was möglich ist dazu würde
übrigens auch gehören dass auch die
amerikaner dann konsequenterweise jeden
import von öl aus russland ist ja auch
noch da dann stoppen würden also
emotional spricht da viele sofort dafür
es braucht halt dann aber auch eine
klare erklärung wie wir das dann auf der
anderen seite schaffen können ein ersatz
zu finden sonst kann das noch sehr kalt
und auch sehr teuer werden also es muss
zumindest ein kompletter plan vorlegen
bevor man eine solche entscheidung
treffen kann und das wird jetzt auch
nicht mit der erneuerbaren energien im
nächsten halben jahr funktionieren da
wird man andere wege finden müssen um es
dann zu machen und zwar sowohl preislich
preis schon kommt jetzt bei allen an
wenn man das beispielsweise an der
zapfsäule sieht und braucht es doch mehr
als die beschlossenen maßnahmen wir
müssen unbedingt runter mit der
mehrwertsteuer einem thema benzin um
eine entlastung zusammen und auf der
anderen seite überlegen wie man dann in
so einem fall überhaupt
ersatzkapazitäten hätte der bund das
klima minister so verstanden dass er
skeptisch ob das geht den plan muss dann
die regierung vor link dann würden wir
uns anschauen aber klar ist
versorgungssicherheit und auch der preis
muss zumindest in einem vernünftigen für
deutschland erhalten werden nicht müde
ihr atomkraftwerk isar 2 in die
waagschale zu werfen und sagen das kann
länger betrieben werden die prüfung von
herrn habe ist noch nicht abgeschlossen
ihre hat ergeben dass sie weiter fahren
könnten er habe die diskussion hat
begonnen in einem bericht bei den
kollegen der ard bericht aus berlin da
ist hat er die debatte begonnen es hat
von uns zunächst mal keiner gemacht wir
haben die debatte dann allerdings
aufgegriffen und in der tat ist es so
wenn man sich anschaut wir sind ja die
genehmigungsbehörde die länder sieht ja
auch seit vielen jahren erfahren ist ein
technisch wäre es jetzt kein problem es
geht auch nicht um die frage jetzt von
einem halben jahr oder einem jahr
sondern die frage ist doch wenn wir zu
viele gewissheiten die wir bislang
hatten neu diskutieren also hat man alle
karten auf den tisch legen jetzt allein
zu sagen wir brauchen nur mehr kohle ist
sicherlich nicht der ansatz erneuerbare
energien sicher da würden wir zum
beispiel sehr gern haben dass wenn wir
es so ist dass die versorgungssicherheit
auch wichtiger als das andere fragen bei
uns mehr möglichkeiten für die
wasserkraft gehen es würde uns neben bin
sehr viel helfen da voranzukommen auch
im bereich der biomasse haben wir enorme
potenziale das dritte kurzfristig
natürlich werde auch die frage ob wir
nicht ewig sondern drei vier jahre der
fünf jahre für den jetzigen übergang die
atomenergie versuchen warum aus ganz
einfachen gründen es ist billig es ist
sicher die energie und vor allen dingen
sie ist absolut klimafreundlich weil es
nicht nur zwei bis fünf jahre haben sie
gesagt wir gehen nochmals zu marina
weisband nach und münster er verweist
man die nicht einfach zu beantwortende
frage erstens wie reagiert die ukraine
auf diese waffenlieferungen die da aus
deutschland bisher kamen und kommen und
zweitens finden sie dass diese
sanktionen eben auch ein vollständiges
embargo der öl- und gasleitungen braucht
die der westen noch bezieht
das aus der ukraine es ist ja so wir
haben dieses thema systeme geliefert und
das sind alte nva beständen die die mit
denen die ukrainische regierung aber
auch einverstanden war das heißt sie
wussten das sind alte bestände die wurst
man könnte möglicherweise etwas nicht in
ordnung sein genau aber sie haben gesagt
okay liefert aber trotzdem weil unsere
das sind daran ausgebildet die können
sie selbstständig reparieren es ist
besser ist nichts gebt uns bitte alles
was ihr habt weil wir werden hier gerade
überrannt
ich habe jetzt allerdings von den leuten
die die dinge einsetzen sollen auch
nachrichten bekommen dass die leute viel
platz und davon danken die das sie
verrostet sind dass sie nicht
funktionieren das ist ja mitunter also
hier in deutschland dürfen sie nicht
eingesetzt werden sie hätten
verschrottet werden müssen vor einer
weile schon weil sie gefährlich sind und
klar für einen soldaten der ukraine ist
gar keine waffe gefährlicher ist eine
dysfunktionale waffe aber es hinterlässt
einen schönen geschmack gerade nach den
5000 themen die ukraine hoffen natürlich
auf jede unterstützung zumal ein
militärischer sieg jetzt plötzlich gar
nicht mehr so
unerreichbar erscheinen und das ist
übrigens nicht nur selen cigs verdienst
ich möchte mich dagegen aussprechen dass
die bedeutung dieses einen mannes
überbewertet wird er ist ohne jeden
zweifel ein sehr tapferer präsident
genau der mann den es gerade braucht in
der ukraine aber selbst wenn er fällt
selbst wenn er kapitulieren würde würden
die ukrainischen leute weiter kämpfen
also digital impfen das machen sie
unabhängig von ihm
genau und was uns betrifft
die aktion ich meine wie zynisch ist es
dass wir einerseits ganz ganz viel
humanitäre hilfe versprechen und waffen
versprechen und auf der anderen seite
letzten endes die hotellerie
mitfinanzieren didaktischen leuten auf
die köpfe fällt
dieses geld eben in die sämtlichen hoch
und auf rüstungsprogramme von wladimir
putin gegangen